Vanderpump rules star scheana Marie and  Mike Shay are officially divorced  et can confirm with the split Sheena  will now have to pay Mike $50,000 in  order to balance out their assets a 2016  Ford Explorer a 2009 Nissan and $31,000  are among the things she will get to  keep with party everything isn't  supposed to last forever this is this  but you know I'm writing the couples I  Do's ups and downs played out on the  Bravo reality series when you say for  better for worse you think it's just for  better but quickly we learned what the  four worst part of our vows was the pair  initially called it quits in November  2016 after over two years of marriage  and scheana has already moved on from  her ex with producer Robert Valletta  [Music]  you